joining me now in the studio is Fabio
Carbone he's the icrc regional director
for near in Middle East
Welcome to our desert thanks very much
thank you for coming in
we'll get into each individual country
in just a second but first more
generally as I just said the the region
middle east region has long been
afflicted by conflicts and all these
other issues tell us more about the
difficulties that the region faces and
the challenges that you have to deal
with I mean before speaking about the
challenges I believe we need to
acknowledge that over the last two three
years there is diplomatic efforts to try
to address the crisis in the region
through diplomatic means and and I think
we need to acknowledge that we're not
where we were four or five years ago
with this this big battles and and
massive confrontation so there is this
genuine effort we see it in in Yemen we
see it also in Syria there's an effort
but is there progress
I think you know to reach a political
solution
um you need to build trust you need to
build confidence because at one stage
you need to compromise
and if we look back to what happened
over the last 12 years 13 years I think
we need to uh to look with a positive
attitude uh the efforts which are taking
place today but as you said
um we still need to demonstrate for the
people of this region that there are
positive dividends uh for them and
that's probably
where we are a bit concerned because if
we look at the people of the region Iraq
Syria Lebanon Yemen Palestine
situation is really dire right and for
many it's hard to see any any positivity
at all you talk about Syria you went
there shortly after the earthquake I
think you had years of conflict and then
the earthquake what kind of things did
you see and what was your takeaway from
it
what is hard in in Syria and especially
the area affected by the the earthquake
it's it's actually for instance Aleppo
it's the area which was also the hardest
hit by the conflict so you had people
who had to struggle uh living in in the
rubbles of the city and on top of this
they had to manage
um the earthquake but what I what stays
with me
um from I mean I was there just two days
after the earthquake is is
I mean though the people of this region
the people of of Aleppo
um they were the first one to response
to the crisis you know
um because they were pretty much left
alone with the situation so as I say I
see we we intervene quite quickly within
I mean the same night with the Syria
Arabic Crescent but at the end of the
day the size of the challenge the size
of the devastation you know was such
that we couldn't compensate we couldn't
cope with the size of the child the
people had to take the situation in
their own hand it was sad and and
um and a bit frustrating to be honest
and in Syria and in other regions like
Yemen the problems the issues are made
worse by the fact that they're deeply
politicized especially look that's the
thing you know
um I believe solution will come through
a political process and you might tell
an action is just buying time allowing
people to cope with the situation Till
There is a real solution which is a
political solution and what we face over
the last year is that the lack of
political process or the lack of
political progress actually affected you
might have an action because when you
don't have political progress you use
your mightieran action and that's why
often you might enter an action was and
is uh politicized and who's paying the
price
obviously the people of Syria the people
of Palestine the people of Yemen the
people of Iraq as we come to the end a
big issue as well of course is is
funding money is what's required and
that that has dwindled yeah I think the
situation I mean it's overwhelming
because there's a climate crisis the
consequence of the conflict and and we
see that funding is decreasing so
obviously we want our traditional donors
to do more but we also need uh other
actors to come in you know I think we
need to the the burden needs to be
shared by way more actors than the one
who uh who who pay for humanitarian
action over the last 10 12 years and
what about all the other issues and
we've talked about conflict specifically
but climate change the effects of covid
and so forth I think this is a
cumulative effect you know and and I
think the climate change is probably the
one causing very big concern for us
because it you can't separate anymore
conflict from uh I would say a climate
crisis and and on top of this what we
see is that you need resources to
address the climate crisis I mean the
the droughts in in Yemen with uh
following uh floods you need to address
this with climate money and we see that
all the money for
um for addressing the challenge of the
climate crisis is not going towards the
countries which are most affected and
which often are the ones facing
situation of conflict and violence so
it's a really vicious circle of course
and the thing with climate change is not
just an environmental issue it's also
and more importantly for the millions
concerned it's it's a an economic
problem isn't it it's it's public health
because you don't have water it's
economy because obviously if your office
is affected you cannot grow what is
needed for food but also to to to uh to
Kickstart the economy so it's a
you can't isolate the climate crisis
from all the aspects of life and that
what makes it uh very urgent not just
for humanitarian actors but for the
whole International Community observing
those situations of conflict and
instability to be serious about it and
and to to channel the necessary funding
and Technology towards those those areas
affected by by conflict it's not
happening today
absolutely not and it really there is
really a need to change perspective
what's your message to the International
Community
in your effort here to try and help
these nations recover from the issues
that they face I I think
what what allows the the the region to
to be a bit more peaceful than what we
had four or five years ago it's because
we mainly address the security agenda
but the structural causes structural
issue
um causing this situation in of
instability it's access to education
it's access to health it's in in summary
to know that tomorrow will be better
than than today and uh while the
security agenda is important if we don't
pay attention
to the other root causes of violence the
risk is to have again more instability
and there I think mainly about the
millions of people who are still
displaced thinking about the people who
are still detained thinking about the
thousands of people who went missing and
their families staying without news
creating a level of anxiety which in our
view will make the transition towards a
more stable and peaceful uh region more
difficult
Fabricio Carboni the icrc regional
director for near Middle East thank you
very much thank you for joining me